éclatée éclaté lui une touche est pas me
frapper partout
là c'est là que j'ai commencé à faire
quoi que chez quand ça marche pas je
parle à mon bureau j'ai hurlé
ils me regardaient qui était comme ça
c'est qu'est ce que je tenterai de faire
lever la maison afin qu'ils lui étaient
enragés moi je mettais à bari dans sa
tombe et j'avais peur je ne sais pas si
je suis pas une soirée mitigée c'est
fait on entend dans cet extrait la
détresse l'impuissance la peur de cette
femme victime de violences conjugales
violences se trouvent souvent
meurtrières c'est d'ailleurs un extrait
du documentaire face au monde qui sera
diffusé ce soir sur les ondes de la télé
de radio canada ici radio canada télé
c'était à 21h cette violence est
toujours d'actualité trop souvent
d'actualité
ne serait-ce qu aujourd'hui on entend la
couronne devant des 50 ans de prison
pour hugues aufray d'être qui a tué son
ex conjointe véronique barbe qui a vécu
cette détresse et cette impuissance
vraiment dans une spirale infernale et
qui n'est peut-être pas parti attend que
n'a pas su partir et on apprenait aussi
aujourd'hui au réveil le meurtre de deux
enfants de 5 et 70 aux mains de leur
père qui s'est par la suite enlevé la
vie alors un drame il imaginable alors
c'est beaucoup de compréhension je parle
ce soit avec ingrid falaise pourquoi
mais parce que c'est elle a su
transformer sa propre histoire
un message d'espoir dans sa série le
mans c'est aussi dans ce documentaire
hollywood ingrid falaise merci d'être
avec nous aujourd'hui à 24,60 une
journée qu'on ne voudrait pas voir trop
souvent mais malheureusement se
retrouvent souvent aujourd'hui encore un
père qui suit ses deux enfants morts
alors complet de la cour une peine
exemplaire pour gouffre dette qui a tué
son ex conjointe qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire encore aujourd'hui moment où
votre documentaire ce soir va être
président
canada face au monde c'est sûr que je
suis dévasté ce qui s'est passé ce matin
mais c'est la réalité
alors je souhaite que la population se
lève avec moi que les élus quel ministre
que les députés nous entendent changer
les choses
vous commencez à la base le ouais alors
il faut prévenir il faut faire changer
les failles du système
d'ailleurs votre documentaire commence
sur une promesse politique 1994 1995 je
sais par les au premier ministre du
québec donc promet de changer les choses
et vous fait un constat très brutale
dont est dramatique
le récit que vous en faites extrêmement
dramatique
on n'est pas là pour remplir le premier
au nom en 1995 jacques parizeau demande
à ses ministres d'unir leurs voix pour
mettre en place un plan d'action pour
faire changer les choses en matière de
violence amoureuse au québec
24 ans plus tard peu de choses ont
changé oui il ya eu des avancées
quelques avancées mais il ya des
recommandations qui s'empilent sur le
bureau des ministres et les ministres
changent aux quatre ans you port assez
de choses qui changent il faut bouger
des montagnes et revente est
complètement le système de justice parce
que le système de justice dont l'oeil à
hugo fraudeurs qui est condamné on verra
ses 25 ans 50 ans de 2 500 m2 une prison
à vie mais quand ce procès se déroulait
on ne pouvait pas vraiment parler par
respect de du processus judiciaire pour
influencer un jury entre bon mais quand
on apprend qu'il y avait quand même des
interventions qui avait quand même des
des thérapeutes impliqués mais quelqu'un
elle avait peur elle vivait dans la peur
x elle est morte quand même il ya
quelque chose d'une sorte de
particulièrement révoltant dans mais on
s'y intéresse quand les femmes marion 11
femmes qui meurent chaque année faut que
ça cesse alors faut revenir à la base
vous que la violence psychologique la
manipulation le contrôle la domination
faut que ce soit reconnue ici au québec
je le dis dans documentaire est reconnu
au pays dé galles les gens qui exercent
la manipulation la domination le
contrôle peuvent écoper d'une peine de
deux à cinq ans alors ça ça fait bouger
les choses parce qu'on veut - l'utiliser
si indécent
ici au québec violence psychologique
pattesbleues ça s'est passé hier est
brouillonne rien avant et c'était la
pire violence
oui parce qu'elle peut utilement finir à
la violence physique mais cette spirale
de vous raconter dans la série s'est
inspiré de votre histoire
mais cette fameuse spirale cette fameuse
spirale dont on ne peut pas se sortir
sur une femme ou même un homme parce que
dans le documentaire il ya un ovni
témoigne aussi de violence
évidemment les statistiques vont dans
l'autre en exil en plus de femmes c'est
la majorité moi c'était une chose à dire
à une femme qui vous écoutent et qui vit
ce drame là c'est d'être et cela un
dernièrement qui a peur de quitter parce
que le documentaire le montre aussi
souvent c'est la peur de quitter c'est
la peur de mourir exclusive que ce que
vous avez vu les images j'ai envie de
dire écoute ta petite voix intérieure
et c'est pas de ta faute c'est lui qui
t'a amené à te détruire c'est lui qui
l'a détruit c'est lui qui a avec des
petits coups d'ici sur l'art de
l'estiment de soit on a oublié tomber à
terme et si possible de se reconstruire
c'est possible de marcher avec la tête
haute les épaules fier et d'avoir une
belle vie sans violence
et c'est ça le message que vous vous
portez d'internet mais c'est ce que j'ai
envie que les femmes reconnaissent et
surtout que c'est pas de notre faute et
par les fauves briser ce silence il faut
dénoncer parce que et m
comme je les appelle les monstres leur
âme la plus forte de ces pervers
narcissique l'os et de nous entretenir
dans silence comme ça ils nous
contrôlent davantage et nous isole
davantage donc de parler de briser ce
silence a new sort de l'isolément et ça
peu mais ça peut guérir surtout sauver
des vies et coupe de famille à part ça
les détruise tout l'entourage courage
pour avoir un contrôle total ou un pied
dans l'autre exemple dramatique
d'aujourd'hui c'est super qu'ils
préfèrent que choisir nos jours josh je
fasse c'est mourir parce qu'on doit on
choisir cette fois pourquoi le suicide
est horrible puis on emporte le public a
dû souvent bon le l'homme qui fait ça
parce qu'il va emporter les enfants avec
lui c'est une forme de délire j'imagine
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour ce saison bien
s'ils ne sont pas capables d'accepter la
réalité au départ mais déplacer des gens
qui sont extrêmement contrôle et lorsque
la femme comme cette femme qui était en
processus de séparation le degré de
dangerosité est à son maximum parce que
les pervers narcissique sont extrêmement
contrôlant donc ils perdent le contrôle
quand la femme désire quitter
c'est pour ça que c'est si difficile de
quitter aussi ils peuvent se rendre
jusque là il femmes doivent planifier
leur fuite
tranquillement cacher le passeport
appeler à l'aide
appelé dans les centres d'hébergement à
voir là jamais retourner seul comme
daphné boudreau a fait les retourner
seul chercher son cellulaire qu'elle
avait laissé chez anthony prat
ils l'ont tué j'admets retourner seul
même si on pense que mais à moi ça
n'arrivera jamais oui ça peut entraîner
la mort c'est apprendre c'est vraiment à
prendre au sérieux
c'est absolument bouleversant de vous
entendre il ya quand même un communiqué
qui sorti aujourd'hui qui est liée à
l'effet de votre série une augmentation
du nombre d'appels dans les ressources
d'hébergement
mon horaire on n'arrive pas à répondre à
la demande
non il faut débloquer des fonds il ya
9500 femmes qui font dire non chaque
année elle demande l appel elles ont le
courage d'appeler et de demander une
place en maison d'hébergement avec leurs
deux enfants ce libre on refuse parce
que pas assez de place il faut débloquer
des fonds d'urgence pour les aider ces
femmes là parce qu'elles peuvent mourir
alors cette femme qui appelle saison n'a
pas de place à quoi qu'est ce qu'elle
fait elle se retourne vers sa famille
celle de la famille moi j'avais la
chance d'avoir ma famille celles qui
n'en ont pas qu'est ce qu'elles font
elles restent avec leurs bourreaux
parce que la dimension économique
absurde même partielle à la manipulation
oui la violence financière également
entre en ligne de compte de marie qui va
gérer les impôts qui va gérer les
finances qui va gérer qui va tout gérer
on le voit dans les séries s et si
j'avais pu rien j'avais même pas 25 sous
pour appeler au téléphone par c'est
comme ça qu'ils contrôlent si c'est
comme ça qu'ils hall alors où est ce
qu'elle se retourne je sais pas parce
que c'est des gros problèmes de société
et de santé psychologique de santé de ce
qui a primé des problèmes sociaux
pension aux enfants qui sont impliqués
là blanc il y en a deux
puce wi forme absolument et moi je veux
changer aussi la façon de penser de la
société et les journalistes ont leur pas
à faire enlever le mot crime passionnel
de vocabulaire même si ça fait vendre
des journaux
c'est important de changer la mentalité
un meurtre c'est un meurtre oui dans un
aspect de violences conjugales mais
c'est de la violence conjugale
donc il faut vraiment changer notre
façon de parler et pourquoi je te vois
pas eu de violence amoureuse la violence
amoureuse c'est que c'est la façon de
redéfinir parce que la violence
conjugale salette à interpeller les
jeunes alors que la violence amoureuse
commence à l'âge de 12 ans 13 ans 14 ans
très très très très tôt et je donne
énormément de conférences dans les
écoles d'ailleurs et la violence
amoureuse comment ce jeune a commencé
avec amour vous dites dans mes chaque
histoire de violence conjugale violence
amoureuse commence par une histoire
d'amour sinon il y en aurait pas alors
c'est important d'interpeller nos gènes
ou celle et sensibilisé très tôt à ce
que c'est la violence amoureuse
alors certains beauté de ce que c'est
une survivante nom de plus vous avoir
entendu falaise rappelle votre
documentaire face au mans ce pré diffusé
ce soir sur ici radio canada télé c'est
sur tou.tv puis à la série est également
merci d'avoir transformé votre drames
personnels et de l'avoir mis un coup sur
deux de la société temis
merci merci